opportunity for us to collaborate together.
We'll be happy to put in some investment from our side,
work on a POC with any of your clients.
See how we can scale together.
Yeah, that works. I have a list ready. Talk through.
Yeah. Should we do that first or do you want
Tamancha to walk you through some of the,
we can do either first.
Yeah. Where I've seen us accelerate partner engagement,
so for example,
like V4C is partner of the year and they started
last year as a lesser known partner.
Which one?
V4C.
Okay.
What they've done really well is just become
an extension of our sales team versus
a partner led engagement.
I want us to get to that steady state because we are,
for the most part,
it's just really easy to bring them in because they
always come in and they land their programs and then they'll
push customers back to us and say sign the data versus contract,
and then that will unlock all of these additional services for
you around Short Hills.
Then we're using that as pipeline building for the Short Hills team as well.
So we've done that for the V4C team similarly.
That's why it's really easy to work with them.
So I love to understand your offering and then figure out how we can
tailored it to that story to accelerate more engagement for you guys
and bring in more teammates to the short-term product offerings.
Then I'd be to share more about my accounts and see if there's
any current engagements with you guys there or pick a few out to run that together.
Does that sound good?
Yeah.
Cool.
Right.
Jivisin, just one small thing.
You are bringing up your screen or should I just read?
Yeah.
Himanshu, you should just quickly walk through some of
the use cases that we have worked on.
Got it.
Then Jefferson will have a better idea on what we have done with other plans.
Great.
Jivisin, I would give you a very quick run on.
I created a small deck.
Let me know once my screen is visible to you.
Let me know once it's visible.
Yeah.
Yes, visible.
All right.
Great.
I'll give you a little bit of a rundown.
Ranjitha already mentioned that we are Databricks' Silver Tier partners.
In addition to being Silver Tier partners, we are also BrickBuilder partners.
We carry at this point of time BrickBuilder Genai badge with us.
It's not just the marketing badge.
We actually have used our Accelbate code bricks that we created to bring customers
to Databricks faster.
Awesome.
Then these clients, they're also Databricks' customers as well?
Yeah.
Great.
Some of these customers are on various different platforms, but these are some of our customers.
I think one of them is also on Databricks.
Okay.
Which one?
This one.